was haltet ihr davon dass er ein spiel
die minecraft verboten werden sollte
löst in meiner lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen hier zu den neuen
folgen
mir wurden wieder extremsten effekt
zugesendet und irgendwann geht die noch
kaputt in die höhe
und ich hab mir wieder fünf rausgesucht
wenn ihr auch erkennen könnt ihr mir die
gerne alle und in die kommentare
schreiben weil daher nehme ich die im
heute werde ich auch endlich mal die
namen erwähnen von den leuten die mir
die zugesendet haben die letzten mal
hatte ich dass er immer irgendwie
vergessen weil ich verteilt bin und ich
will da wir verteidigen freuen wenn ihr
bis zum ende dran bleibt dann das video
am ende
guck mal hier sehen wir auch noch mal in
die bis zum ende dran bleiben würde und
dann erst das video bewertet weil ich
jetzt tot wenn man das vorher bewertet
weil wir nicht da hat man ihn nicht
kannte video gesehen und & jerry's
musiker wieder das perfekte beispiel
dass die sonnenblumen immer so entgegen
der sonne wachsende das schon super aber
das habe ich auch schon mal vorgestellt
aber ich will ja nicht so viel reden wir
fangen an mit fact nummer 1 weg nummer
eins wurde mir zugesendet von der liebe
nette es punkt und zwar erkenne das
natürlich ich mache mir hier
beispielsweise erst mal so redstone in
der höhle und wir kennen das ich laufe
da rüber und die teile werden aktiviert
beziehungsweise ich stelle mich einfach
drauf das sieht man das denke ich ein
bisschen besser dass ihr dann extrem
viel partikel rauskommen und viel mehr
partikel als beispielsweise bei denen
davon auf denen ich nicht drauf stehe
ich kann ihn einmal so ein bisschen
drüber laufen dann geht ihr schon und
eventuell auch wenn ich mal den shader
rausnehmen sieht man das auch noch mal
ganz gut vor allem auch in der nacht
sieht man das extrem gut weil die teile
dann sogar so ein bisschen leuchten
meine ich ja also ich denke man kann das
ganz gut erkennen dass nach vorne
wirklich nahezu gar keine partikel
rauskommen und hier einfach extrem viele
dann packe ich mir mal eben schnell
wieder diesem shader rein und zwar liegt
das ganze daran dass ich einfach nicht
das erkennt man mit dem staat einfach
überhaupt nicht gut da mit dem soll
schilder kann man das ganze ganz
interessant erkennen und 2 seht ihr hier
schon ja da kommt richtig für partikel
raus weil ich darüber laufe wenn ich
hier drüber lauf ist das ganze auslöse
das sind keine modifizierten redstone
sache oder irgendwie so allerdings wenn
ich darüber snicket dann kommen da nicht
so viele partikel raus beziehungsweise
nahezu gar keinen also wenn jetzt mal
seht hier da kommen nur diese ganz
normalen partikel raus nach vorne kommen
sie auch ganz normal raus also ihr seht
schon wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal das
nicken wegnehme dann seht ihr kommen da
wieder extrem viele partikel raus wenn
ich jetzt allerdings wieder sneaker
die partikel verschwinden es kommen ja
immer partikel aus dem netz in sachen
raus allerdings vergleicht mal diese
anzahl von partikeln wenn ich jetzt
wächst nickel mit dieser anzahl von
partikeln also die partikel kommen nur
auf bei dem redstone wenn ich da
wirklich drüber sneaker wenn ich dann
nicht drüber ist nicola freude das ist
der effekt nummer eins zu gesendet wurde
von jetta es punkt und zwar einfach wenn
ich über redstone sneaker wird er nicht
aktiviert beziehungsweise die partikel
kommen dann quasi nicht also ganz normal
wenn ich allerdings darüber laufe dann
kommen die partikel die ganz normal bzw
ihr seht schon hier die partikel sind
viel mehr als wenn ich jetzt mal
beispielsweise liegen würde
fact nummer zwei wurde wir zugesellt von
sweety und zwar wie viel grad schon
einen ender christus pontes sehen wir
auch daran hier einfach seine länder
christi länder enter drücken dann haben
wir einander kristall ich finde ja immer
noch die sehen extrem cool aus in diesem
shadertakt es sieht einfach so nennt
mich so ein bisschen league of legends
ich weiß nicht was diese kuh mit den
sachen hier machen will
aber naja naja ich hab noch nicht league
of legends so richtig gespielt habe dass
mir damals ein bisschen gezockt aber
irgendwie erinnert mich diese ganze
animation und die farben und so an das
spiel die jedenfalls ist es möglich
diese ender krstic mit schneebällen zu
zerstören ihr kennt das ja ganz normal
ich die auf eine kuh beispielsweise los
wären sie mit schneebällen ab damit
könnte ich nie die köthen das einzige
was ich machen kann ist glaube ich place
trotz töten und so sachen aus
irgendwelchen schildern rausnehmen bzw
so entities einfach entfernen so was wie
rüstung ständer oder so was meine ich
bin mir jetzt auch nicht so sicher
allerdings läge schon wenn ich einen
schneeball offenen endes gewerke
explodiert das ganze ding dass andere
jetzt selbstverständlich auch ich war
hier einfach
freunde das ist das problem wenn ihr ein
shortcut abrunden witherspoon
das ist nicht wahr so spawnen wie man
noch ein ender kristall und zwar seht
ihr schon wenn ich den mit einem
schneeball abwerfe explodiert das ganze
ding das heißt mit einem schneeball kann
ich ein ender kristall zum explodieren
bringen
ich hoffe dass ich das ganze jetzt noch
hier vernünftig aufnehmen kann oder dass
der ritter boss dahinten mir die ganze
welt um die ohren jagd aber das war auf
jeden fall schonmal effekt nummer 2 der
dritte weg wurde mir zugesendet von luis
w punkt und zwar als bin ich wieder bei
den reds in sachen ich setze ich jetzt
mal einfach eine seelen samt helm und
dann setze ich hier noch eben schnell
einen zombie kopf einen normalen kopf
und ein kluger kopf hin und jetzt
vergleicht man die texturen also hier
eine seelen sahen textur einfach platt
und eine zombie kopf texte wenn ich die
abbau und eine normale kopf texte
welchen abbau und einen creeper kopf
animationen wenn ich den abbau
die partikel sind nämlich genau die
gleichen wie vom seelen sein also
vergleicht ist noch mal hier
zack seelen sand hier zack kopf das ist
nämlich ganz einfach so weil dieser kopf
mehr oder weniger hat so die seele denk
ich mal darstellen soll von einem
spieler bzw von einem mob deswegen haben
die partikel genauso gemacht wie bei
seelen sand das ist auf jeden fall auch
eine ganz interessante sache die denke
ich noch nicht
schon vor einigen aufgefallen ist
arbeitsgruppe auf jeden fall zugesagt
von luis w punkt die partikel sind die
gleichen wie abbau grafik ist die
gleiche bei seelen sind wie wenn ich
einen kopf ab bauer ich denke einfach
dass es daran liegt dass sie sich
dachten ja oh das ist im kopf das ist
eine seele mehr oder weniger machen wir
doch einfach die gleichen partikel und
ja das war auch schon fag nummer drei so
freunde effekt macht ihr wollt mir
zugesendet von mario z punkt und zwar
das etwas damit zu tun was ich vorhin
schon gespannt hat und zwar diesem
werbespot
ich schaue mich alles schon so an als
wichtig alle umbringen wollen also
möchte ich auch mehr oder weniger
ich wollte nämlich eben einen ritter
boss der bringt jetzt erstmals ein
papierchen und so weiter und so fort
jedenfalls seht ihr schon oben
eingeblendet steht ja immer und zwar ist
effekt wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal
einfach das spiel pausiert steht da oben
immer noch mutter jetzt gehe ich
speichern und zurück zum hauptmenü jetzt
beispielsweise mal auf 1
ebenen server drauf und zwar connect ich
jetzt einfach mal zu gome hd punkt nett
und jetzt achtet oben im bildschirm
steht noch ganz kurz ritter jetzt ist es
auch schon wieder weg und zwar wie
twitter einfach noch ganz kurz angezeigt
nachdem ich auf dem server genau das
gleiche auch ich befinde mich hier
wieder in der welt ihr seht oben ritter
eingeblendet ich gehe in den escape
modus ist escape sks kate modus ich gehe
immer mehr spieler etwas leichter finden
scheint jedenfalls ich connect jetzt
beispielsweise auf dem leben server und
ihr seht schon oben der eingeblendet
steht kurz wynter also wenn ich einen
ritter in meiner normalen singles born
in das menü gehe und danach wieder auf
einem multiplayer server gesteht oben
noch ganz kurz bilder eingeblendet das
hat der mario z punkt aus gefunden und
wir machen weiter mit command nummer mit
5,05 ist etwas was wir jetzt schon
eingeblendet seht und zwar ist das ein
artikel der online zeitschrift game ohne
oder gar monat wenn wir nicht ganz
sicher wie das ausgesprochen wird
jedenfalls kursiert das jetzt zur zeit
in den news und zwar soll minecraft in
der türkei verboten werden weil es zu
viel zu viel gewalt im hält ich zitiere
jetzt mal aus diesem artikel
daher ist man der meinung einige kinder
könnten die virtualität von der realität
nicht unterscheiden und glauben
gefolterte tiere würden keinen schmerz
empfinden
auch sieht man in der sozialen
isolierung einer gefahr während die
online komponente möglicherweise zum
mobbing schrecklich beleidigungen führen
könnte
damit ein solches verbot aber umgesetzt
werden kann muss noch ein gericht
entscheiden also quelle gamona punkt.de
jetzt grad schon eingeblendet was haltet
ihr von dieser ganze sache es ging ja
zurzeit echt häufig durch irgendwelche
gaming webseiten gaming news
irgendwelche
nachrichtensender haben darüber in
artikeln informiert und so weiter
was haltet ihr davon dass ein spiel die
minecraft verboten werden soll ich meine
es ist glaube ich in deutschland ab
sechs jahren freigegeben oder irgendwie
so und es ist jetzt echt nicht
gewaltverherrlichend also es gibt ja
auch spiel in der türkei die denke ich
erlaubt sind so was wie call of duty
oder was fertig andere beispiele gibt es
zu kaufen deswegen verstehe es nicht so
ganz wieder eine regierung so über
empfindlich sein kann allgemein die
tatsache dass spiele einen zu
gewalttaten anregen kann es so blöd
finde ich meinen se ich habe auch mit
mit 14 15 jahren schon die ersten spiele
gespielt die ich in meinem alter noch
nie spielen durfte und ich habe zurzeit
keine gewalttaten irgendwie getan also
ich finde es kommt er immer auf die
person an sichern und die physischen
eigenschaften wenn dann nämlich
beispielsweise jemand ist das weiß ich
noch vor ein paar jahren war es so der
hatte irgendwie ein paar leute halt
umgebracht was natürlich überhaupt nicht
weil sie das ist überhaupt nicht zu
verantworten so was einfach aber es wird
dann von den medien immer gesagt ja er
hatte ballerspiele auf dem pc aber darum
dass er zu hause geschlagen wurde und
gemobbt wurde in der schule und so wurde
einfach total außen vor gelassen
ich meine die regierung möchte sich da
immer so ich weiß nicht was dazu sagen
soll ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viel
sagen weil vielleicht haben einige hier
andere andere wertevorstellungen
beziehungsweise sehen das ganze auch
einfach anders ich weiß allerdings nicht
was haltet ihr davon würdet ihr sagen
minecraft ist ein sehr gefährliches
spiel sollte verboten werden oder nicht
wenn der letzten folge wird der kreis
diskutiert über die dänemark sache und
so das fand ich ganz cool deswegen wenn
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir jetzt nur
über diese sache diskutieren würden ich
find die welt geht übrigens wieder sehr
schön so richtig eisig kalt bei uns
draußen zweitrat 17 grad und sonne
ja das war einfach eine sache die mir so
selbst quasi ein gefallen ist weil ich
einfach so krass in den medien gehabt
wurde dieses thema das minecraft
verboten werden soll
das war's dann aber auch schon mit dem
effekt wenn es euch gefallen hat freunde
die folgen jetzt vorbei war natürlich
meine bewertung freuen wenn ihr es habt
schreibt bin jedoch in die kommentare
ich werde mich bemühen der nächsten
folge auch wieder die leute zu erwähnen
die wir die effekt zugewendet haben dass
wir auf jeden fall mega cool denn da
einige text wieder dran kommen würden
und dann würde ich sagen wünsche ich
euch noch einen wunderschönen tag
sorry das gestern kein video kam aber
das wird auch in nächster zeit nahezu
öfters mal so sein weil bald wieder vor
so phase ist und ich
teilweise echt von 9 bis 20 uhr nach
umwegen lernen und alles aber naja ich
krieg das schon alles irgendwie hin wir
sehen uns dann in einem nächsten video
wieder sondern abschieds ich muss mal
immer eine coole variante